[Música]
bom a a minha história é um pouco
diferente porque ela não é minha é nossa
como introdução é que já mostrou esse
problema de fake news não é um problema
isolado
todos nós estamos vivendo é essa
situação porque porque nós estamos no
mundo em transição o mundo hoje é
híbrido
a gente vive numa mistura de mundo real
eo mundo digital e cada vez passamos
mais tempo no mundo digital e nesse
nesse contexto que a gente está vivendo
e cada vez né essa situação será
profunda é é tem um problema que surge
que é a verdade
a construção da verdade como é que se
continua a verdade nesse novo contexto é
de mundo híbrido eu vou começar com a
motivação já teve uma introdução à minha
prima é essa mensagem que eu falei pra
vocês minha prima simone mora em
sorocaba o marido dela é médico e
trabalha no hospital de sorocaba e pedir
pra avisar nossa família e amigos na
popular grupo da família e pára de jeito
nenhum tomar a vacina da febre amarela
que é para nos proteger com repelente e
inseticida telas nas janelas porque a
vacina da febre amarela de alguma forma
pode fazer mal às pessoas
isso supostamente escrito por um médico
é esse tema é de saúde ele é recorrente
nessas mensagens que são falsas
tá pra gente verificar isso é muito
simples mas porque o tema de saúde é
recorrente porque ele chama a nossa
atenção
você recebe o negócio é se você acende o
beach ele fica prestando atenção para
ver se isso procede se não procede
na magna grande maioria dos fada dos
casos é falso
tá então é então entrando no tema nessa
dessa conversa é é verdade quando nós
recebemos uma informação principalmente
um texto uma imagem um vídeo na época
muita gente acredita piamente nos vídeos
mas tem um exemplo clássico de um dvd 1
o discurso de obama precisa por exemplo
estados unidos
nesse discurso ele nunca fez o vídeo foi
todo agitado
usando técnicas de inteligência
artificial então qualquer coisa
representada na forma digital pode ser
alterada pode ser criada pode ser
falsificado e o grande problema atual é
como separar o joio do trigo
principalmente as informações que vêm do
mundo digital
nesse caso dessa mensagem de votos ap é
é trivial
basta escolher algumas das palavras que
apareceram na mensagem fazer uma busca
no google o primeiro site que vem com a
informação é o boato ponto onde a gente
tem vários sites que ficam tentando né
coíbe é a disseminação de informações
falsas
agora notem a water.org ou à agência
lusa o papa e eles são o dono da verdade
eles é o fato de tanto o bota voltou a
criticar alguma coisa significa que
aquilo é mentira a verdade
reparem que é muito complicado isso na
realidade do fundo é o nosso bom senso
que tem que ser utilizado pra gente
separar o que é mentira eo que é verdade
para vocês terem uma idéia de como esse
processo acontece no mundo digital e
porque as pessoas fazem o que leva as
pessoas a ficarem criando informações
como essa de de febre amarela é dizendo
que a vacina faz mal e tem muita gente
que entra nessa pilha e não leva filho
para vacinar e coisas do gênero
mas nós participamos no laboratório do
trabalho na universidade federal da
paraíba
david é em parceria com o fantástico a
convite na realidade da produção do
fantástico é nós fizemos um experimento
ok eo experiente consiste no seguinte
como é que se cria uma informação que
não é verdadeira e se dissemina essa
informação nós junto com o pessoal do
fantástico na área a idéia foi deles
eles criaram uma história sobre um
vidente russo que fazer uma previsão que
o brasil ganharia a copa do mundo né e
aí tem todo um contexto histórico que
esse vidente russo participou de um
programa da kgb que usava vidente para
tentar fazer previsões
isso realmente aconteceu no passado a
cia kgb e outras agências usavam vidente
para tentar entrar mas encontrar pessoas
seqüestradas etc
já então se criou um contexto e aí a
gente começou a publicar essa informação
essa informação nela atingiu cerca de
250 mil pessoas
tá é foi acompanhada de outras por
exemplo logo em seguida nós publicamos
que um milionário russo é havia feito
uma aposta de 300 milhões de dólares no
brasil na bolsa de apostas de londres
recebemos informações de que existem
grupos o whatsapp de investidores
os caras estavam citando a matéria e
discutindo a possibilidade de investir
pra você ter uma idéia de como nessas
coisas se tornam verdade e vamos
entender então como é que se constrói a
verdade no mundo digital
o primeiro passo escrever uma história
nesse caso uma peça de ficção tá segundo
passo publicar isso então como é que
você publica essa informação para que
essa informação tenha credibilidade
então no nosso caso nós criamos um
portal de notícias gazeta rio usando uma
técnica que é muito utilizada
o primeiro jornal impresso do brasil se
chama gazeta do rio e nós criamos o
portal gazeta rio
ok então isso é muito explorado mas se
usa o nome de instituições que já estão
no mercado de de notícias
tira troca o nome faz um trocadilho tiro
uma coisa bota outro e pública esse site
tinha cerca de 1500 notícias verdadeiras
tá e nele nós plantamos uma notícia
falsa que essa era essa previsão do
vidente
o que foi que fizemos na previsão de
ensinar quando publicamos a matéria aqui
tinha uma referência para um site na
inglaterra também um portal de notícias
o voice of manchas e com inúmeras
matérias verdadeiras em inglês e no meio
de uma versão em inglês é da previsão do
vidente do hexa é no voto afirmando que
tinha uma referência para um portal é
homens que era o de importar o russo com
várias matérias em russo verdadeiras e
estava lá não é publicada a história do
vidente ou seja é essa estratégia de
criar portais de notícia
fazer o trocadilho com o nome à pessoa
bate o nome rápido a gente consome
informação muito rápido na internet
então a gente entra ali e é pescado se
interessa se a informação for uma coisa
que nos atinge as pessoas vão lá vão
olhar vão compartilhar e etc
então é nesse processo no mundo digital
porque no mundo real
a gente já tinha nas instituições que
divulgam informações que não
necessariamente são verdadeiras
a gente tem pessoas que divulgam
informações que não necessariamente são
verdadeiras os populares fofoqueiros
agora no mundo digital a gente tem uma
outra estratégia de disseminação de
informação que o uso de robôs está o que
é um robô o basicamente um código para
quem teve alguma experiência de
programação é um pequeno trecho um
programa pequeno que fica ali no nosso
caso nós programamos robôs prato no
twitter
e note zap toda vez que aparece uma
referência a hashtag evidente do hexa
esse robô ativava e aí selecionável um
mundo entre várias frases você não pode
ficar repetindo a mesma coisa porque é
nesse nessa nessa guerra virtual aí a
gente tem os robôs disseminar informação
ea gente tem os caçadores de robôs do
outro lado no twitter no facebook na no
outro só porque ficam tentando impedir a
disseminação de informações na
veiculadas através dessa dessa técnica
essa técnica de veiculação de
informações em redes sociais é ilegítima
é crime não necessariamente tem vários
exemplos de robôs que são ativistas
sociais ativistas e de de ecologia tem
11 tem robôs que fica monitorando por
exemplo os sites da justiça e tuitando o
processo que tão esquisitos que estão
atrasados e 3 então esse tipo de
mecanismo ele pode ser usado para o bem
e na realidade quando a gente olha para
as informações que circulam na internet
60% do que circula na internet é tráfego
gerado por robôs
tá e voltando um pouco ao conceito do
robô e para todos nós temos nossas
presenças na internet
ok então eu tenho o meu perfil no
facebook no twitter e tem lá a minha
conta de outros up todo
nós temos é esse e se depara temos nossa
novela uma espécie de presença com
representação no mundo digital
um robô certo é uma presença no mundo
digital que não corresponde a uma pessoa
no mundo real pode ser usado para o bem
pode ser usado para o mal por exemplo
aqui no brasil sem a gente está num
contexto de eleição
o percentual é de robôs nos candidatos a
30 40 tem candidato que tem 60% dos
seguidores do twitter é é roubo e é
usado para que para disseminar o
programa disseminar as informações
as idéias decidisse candidatos bom pra
concluir essa nossa essa nossa fala
fazer o importante é o seguinte hoje
nesse mundo híbrido é real e digital
como é que acontecem na divulgação de
informações e em muitos casos
informações falsas
primeiro porque se divulgam informação
falsa porque a forma de ganhar dinheiro
público dando informações na internet
ela está associada ao número de vezes
que uma página que uma informação é lida
é compartilhada na hora que a gente
gosta ou não gosta que a gente avalia
que a informação das pessoas que
publicam informação aos profissionais
que buscam formação eles são remunerados
por isso
então se você coloca uma notícia falsa
mas é uma notícia que que pega essa
coisa de saúde sempre pega não é muito
explorado porque muita gente vai ver
muita gente vai compartilhar muita gente
vai passar pra frente
ok e reparem normalmente hoje e os caras
que que atuam nesse mercado eles usam os
exércitos robôs para dar a primeira
espalhada da informação nas redes
sociais a informação ela anda mais ela
atinge mais pessoas mais pessoas é é no
algoritmo que define quem vai receber
uma variável é o número de vezes que a
emac a informação é copiada e isso tem a
ver com a forma como nós aprendemos
certo nós aprendemos o estímulo resposta
por repetição que você recebe a mesma
informação vinda de diferentes fontes
fontes que você não conhece não tem como
avaliar se é um robô ou se é uma pessoa
mas não conhecem então pra você ser uma
fonte digamos assim baixa credibilidade
mas você escutou uma vez que escutou
duas vezes contra três vezes chutou 14
vezes
é simpático aquela informação aí o que
você vai fazer compartilhar
na hora que você compartilha aquela
aquele aquele post do início eu recebi
vindo de minha tia de ana postou aqui no
popular grupo da família
e reparem o que acontece não comigo que
entendo essa história aqui mas minha mãe
que é inepta nessa coisa de de rede
social
recentemente ela aprendeu a usar toda
está recebendo uma informação vinda da
irmã dela uma pessoa em quem ela confia
conhece desde que nasceu então a irmã
dela está emprestando sua credibilidade
a informação está compartilhando ok e aí
nesse experimento que nós fizemos a nós
conseguimos nós tínhamos os robôs já
compramos robôs na rússia ativamos
pagamos bitcoin tudo tem direito
colocamos os robôs para disseminar
informação criamos uma espécie de 1 e 3
disse borges que são pessoas que liberam
não é é o seu perfil do facebook os a
sua conta de outro hábito está para ser
usada e reagir automaticamente a
condições que acontece por exemplo
aparecer lá houve dentro do hexa
então aí é para você tem pessoas que
liberam o uso e ganhando ou não recurso
pra fazer isso a gente tem esse esse
contexto também e por fim a gente tem o
que a gente chama de de camada
institucional das instituições nesse
experimento nós conseguimos não é que
uma instituição um portal de jornalismo
real publicasse a história do vídeo do
hexa ou seja 250 mil pessoas receberam
essa informação e nós conseguimos
convencer pessoas várias pessoas
investidores discutindo se eu não
apostar no brasil por conta da previsão
do vidente do hexa é é nós conseguimos
convencer uma instituição onde tem
formado por jornalistas profissionais
que deveriam ter checado a informação
antes de de emprestar a sua
credibilidade aquela informação
tá então a mensagem que fica aqui no
mundo que nós estamos vivendo que é um
híbrido de real e digital é do vídeo
antes de acreditar
se você leu alguma coisa e sente que tem
alguma coisa esquisita
o consenso do vídeo verifique pesquise
tá e verifique sempre antes de repassar
ok tenha uma situação extrema na nas
eleições americanas
é na última semana surgiu uma denúncia
de que hillary clinton ela era chefe
havia uma organização que que fazia
tráfico de crianças na exploração sexual
de crianças e trava e e apliquem postou
a informação de um endereço diz que a
sede desta organização era uma pizzaria
na flórida o que aconteceu um cara se
armou de faca pistola a r 15
foi lá entrou na cozinha dessa pizzaria
que em que era o centro de comando e
controle dessa organização criminosa
armado e por sorte não matou ninguém
porque lá só tinha gente fazendo pizza
ok mas repare se esse cara tivesse
sentado lá e assassinado alguém as
pessoas que repassaram aquela informação
seriam cúmplices de um assassinato
então não seja cúmplice
obrigado
[Aplausos]